thanks PR and thanks for uh for having
with so I'm really honored to be to be
here um so I'm I'm a philosopher of
science uh interested in in causation
and caal modeling I work on both sort of
Fairly concrete issues about the the net
and bols of Cal modeling uh but also on
sort of much more abstract and high
level issues about uh sort of the
foundations of causal inference and um
how causation and causal inference sort
of fits in a s of physics based picture
of the world and so today my talk is
going to be much more on the abstract
High Level side it's going to be sort of
Fairly disconnected from the sort of
day-to-day methodological issues that
you might face in in science um but
essentially what I'm what I'm going to
focusing on is um this phenomenon that
has puzzled physicists and philosophers
of science for a long time uh which is
that in some sense it's easier to infer
the past uh than the future I'm going to
try to to tell a story as to why that's
the case that I think brings out some
some interesting facts about causal
inference and how sort of the the
physics of our world uh puts constraints
on the the kinds of causal inferences we
can make about the past um or the future
um so so what do I mean when I say uh
that
it's easier to infer the past and the
future I'll tell you in a minute if I
can find a way to move my
slides all right uh so so what do I mean
when I say it's easier to infer the path
in the future well I can give you you
know a couple of perfectly mundane
examples to uh to get to see what I mean
you know if you want to figure out what
the weather was like exactly 10 years
ago in New Heaven uh you can of course
consult the weather records but it's
impossible to predict what the weather
is going to be like in exactly 10 years
uh from now if you see the footprints in
your garden you can figure out you know
a fox visited last night but there's no
there's no sign in your garden that
tells you a fox going to visit tomorrow
night you know you can see the dent in
the car and figure out there's been a
collision recently but again no mark on
the car that tells you uh the car's
going to be involved in a collision in
the future right so so perfectly mundan
examples uh you know looking at more
interesting scientific
examples uh we have all those Sciences
of the deep past like cosmology and
geology and evolutionary biology that
give us very detailed and reliable
accounts of the sometimes very distant
past but we don't have anything like a a
comprehensive scientific account of the
the distant future right and so that's
the sort of phenomenon I'm interested in
of trying to explain at a very um very
general um
level and you might think you know the
explanation for uh the sort of a
symmetry of inference it's obvious uh it
has to do with the fact that the future
by definition hasn't happened yet right
so it's still open and uh that's why we
can't know about it but the past is
settled and it's fixed uh and that's why
we can we can know about it right uh so
there's a couple of issues we've that
but uh perhaps the most obvious one is
that we do of course uh make plenty of
successful predictions about the future
again you know using perfectly mundane
examples to to make the point uh we can
predict when the next solar eclipse is
going to be in the US uh I can see the
cooking the smoke rising from my cooking
pan and figure out that the the fire
alarm is going to beep in a few seconds
so on and so on right U again all this
is perfectly obvious uh so the the
contrast here seems to be really that uh
when it comes to making successful
predictions we're sort of restricted to
very special context like context having
to do with isolated systems like in a
solar system examp example or with uh
the immediate future like in my cooking
pan example or uh you know we can
perhaps make predictions about the
longer term future but they have to be
so very broad brush very vague like I
might predict that you know the Russian
invasion of Ukraine is going to have uh
drastic consequences on the European
geopolitics in 10 years but you know
might not be able to make any more
specific predictions than this uh but
when we turn to inferences toward the
past there's no such restriction right
again we can make of very detailed very
precise inferences about uh sometimes
the very distant past and about systems
like like the weather or species that
are not at all isolated from their
environment uh and whose Dynamics may be
in fact quite quite chaotic right and
the point is a sort of blunt distinction
between an open Future and a fixed f is
not going to be able to explain to
explain that contrast right uh so
presumably
um instead the answer for why it's
easier to infer the past and the future
uh has something to do with the physics
of our world right it has to have some
sort of uh physical
explanation uh but that's somewhat of a
mystery here because um the answer or
the explanation is not going to come
from the the fundamental laws of physics
because the the fundamental laws of
physics are are time symmetric They
Don't Really distinguish between the
past and the future um you know we we've
known since Newton that there's no real
intrinsic direction of determination in
the lose of physics uh earlier states of
the world determine later States just as
much as later states determine earlier
States right so so in relativity theory
for example uh what's going to happen at
time zero here it's going to be fixed by
the cross-section in the backwood light
cone uh but it's also going to be fixed
by the cross section in the future light
right uh so there's no there's no
asymmetry here
um and so there does this this uh so so
that means you know from from the
perspective of the law of physics
there's no real reason to expect the
future to be harder to predict than the
than the
past um so there's this mystery that has
puzzled uh physicists and philosophers
of science for a for a while uh and some
some of the people in this room have
worked on this as well here's some of
the the relevant literature the the
starting point of all of this was u h
rashen Ball's work in in the direction
of time now one idea you find in Ran bar
is that um this asymmetry has to do with
with entropy increase and with the
second LW of thermodynamics so there's a
very sort of influential tradition of
exploring uh that line of thought
there's also an idea you find in Russian
bar that um the asymmetry of inference
as some to do with causation and with
the distinction between causes and
effects uh and with what ran bar called
the principle of the common cause uh so
that's more the line of thought I'm
interested in in exploring today and uh
what I'm going to say sort of
systematize is some of the things that
ran ball says in in his book but that I
think people haven't really picked upon
uh too much in this um in this
literature and so the big picture is
something something like this uh
the kinds of inferences we make toward
the
past and toward the future they are and
they have to be causal inferences they
have to involve cause and effect
reasoning right so inferences toward the
past they always or at least almost
always involve deriving a past cause
from a present effect right only a fox
could have caused those
Footprints uh you know only an organism
with this and that Fe could have
produced the forol that's in front of me
and so on uh and inferences we make
toward the future they involve deriving
a prising a future effect from a from a
present cause right uh the smoke Rising
that's going to to cause the fire alarm
to
beep the Russian invasion that's going
to cause this and that consequence 10
years down the line and so
on
um it's no surprise of course that all
the hypo the all the inferences we make
to the past or the future our caus
because to infer an an event from
another one then it's to be some kind of
correlation between them and correlation
is usually at least going to require
some sort of causal connection between
those two
events and so the hypothesis here um is
that um maybe there something about the
C effect distinction that makes it
easier to infer the cuse uh cuse is a
events uh than than their effects maybe
there's something about the cause effect
distinction that makes it easier to to
infer causes from effects than to infer
effects from from
causes uh and I apologize for the sort
of Mis muching the slide this wasn't
like that on my on my computer
um of course to make good on that
hypothesis you're going to need to
explain what exactly distinguishes
causes from effects and you know why
that distinction would sort of rise to
this
asymmetry um and that question the
distinction between causes and effects
that's also something that has puzzled
physicists and philosophers of science
for a long time again because you know
the fundamental of the physics they're
not really causal They Don't Really
distinguish between past and future they
don't have a direction of determination
so there's sort of a mystery as to how
something like a robust cause effect
distinction emerges from uh from physics
and and like many people I think you
know the the answer at the end of the
day comes from uh the work done in the
causal modeling tradition which which
itself systematizes some ideas of of ran
bar um and the thought here and I assume
you this is this is familiar to
everybody is that uh the kinds of causal
structure we see in our
environment uh they can be represented
in the form of ay graphs uh that
represent relationships of direct
causation between between variables and
the sort of key principle or the key
assumption is that uh there are going to
be some statist some principles that
relate the causal structure of those
systems uh to their statistical
structure and the most important one is
the is the causal Mark of condition uh
that tells you that exogenous variables
sort of um initial causal conditions uh
the causal inputs to your system they're
not going to be correlated with one
another the values are going to be fixed
independently so uh in the model sorry
um in the model over here uh you know s
is not going to be correlated with with
W
um uh but by contrast uh endogenous
variables the effects of the system they
can and usually are correlated with each
other uh at least when they have a
common cause right common causes are
going to create correlations between
between between effects so X and Y for
example here are going to be correlated
because they they have a common C right
so the is at a very general level that's
what the cause effect distinction is
about it's about uh you know uh causes
are the variables that tend to be
statistically independent of one another
and therefore are sort of the causal
inputs of the system and the effects are
those variables that are are correlated
with with one
another um and and what I want want to
try to suggest in the rest of the talk
is that um it is that asymmetry the caal
mark Thea or the asymmetry encoded in
the causal Mark of condition that
explains why it's easier to infer causes
from effects than vice versa and the
claim a bit more precisely is that the
causal Mark of condition is going to
entail in a number of of circumstances
that uh the probability of an effect
given a single one of its causes is
going to be very low uh
except if you're in a special context
where you know you're dealing with an
isolated system or again the effect is
in the immediate future of the c or
something like that um but by contrast
because the caal mark of condition um
doesn't require effects to be
independent of one another it allows for
correlations between them um it's going
to entail that the probability of a cuse
given its effect can be very high even
if the cuse is in the very very distant
uh past and and even if the system we're
dealing with is not is not isolated at
all u i I'll give you an example to try
to sort of make this a bit more Concrete
in a in a second um but one other idea I
want to I want to put on the table here
is that
um when you think about causal
inferences and inferences to the Future
to the Past um there's a kind of mystery
of how limited human you know limited
beings like us can ever in defer
anything about the past or the future
because uh the physics of our world
seems to put a lot of obstacles to that
uh the problem again is um uh or the
problem is that the the dynamical laws
of physics that govern our world uh
they're Global in the sense that uh they
relate Global states of the universe so
again in relativity Theory to figure out
what happens at a space temp point you
need information about the entire
cross-section of the light cone is a
backward or forward and you know
typically that's going to be an enormous
spatial region right and of course we
can't observe Global States right we
have to make do with very localized and
partial
observations so it's kind of a mystery
of how we can use those local
observations to ever predict or
retrodict uh what happens at other times
right given this sort of drastic under
underdetermination uh and the thought
here is going to be that um the causal
Mark of condition or the causal
structure of our world uh it removes
that obstacle it makes it possible to uh
make inferences from local events uh but
um it's going to remove that obstacle
more towards the past than towards the
future as um as you might say there
still still going to be a you know an
enormous epistemic predicament in trying
to figure out what the what the future
is like
um okay um and uh a remark for the for
the philosophers in the room um I
mentioned this this was a line of
thought about the you know the asymmetry
of inference that this has to do with
entropy increase and so on uh the best
version we have of this story today is
is due to to David Albert and you know
you might be wondering what's the what's
the relationship here uh maybe I'll say
a few words about this at the end if I
have the time but uh very roughly the is
the the two stories are sort of
compatible and complement
but there are also some important
nuances about you know how Central the
co symmetry is in sort of the the
picture of the world and how temporal
symmetries emerge from from
physics
um I'm just going to walk uh through an
example here to sort of try to make good
on those various claims I've made here
uh you it's not going to be a very
interesting example of uh you know
historic IAL scientific inference you
know I'm a philosopher I use mundane
examples because uh you know they help
make the points more simply um but the
idea is you know this is this is an
example we can use to think about um you
know inferences at other times in
general including the sort of very
sophisticated inferences you find in uh
evolutionary biology and geology and so
on uh so what you have here on the left
is the the Mayflower departing from pus
in England to America in in
1620 um and here on the right is a is a
random plague I found on the internet um
in Harwick in the UK that that
commemorates the departure of the
Mayflower in in 1620 I mean it says a
number of things but one thing it says
is that uh this this here happened right
and obviously there's a causal
relationship between between those two
um so you know even if you know nothing
about the Mayflower or anything uh as
long as you read English you know you
can walk by that plague read it and then
come to learn that this event happened
right if you go around reading plagues
you know you'll get it right most of the
time the time plages are really reliable
right um so it's very very easy to make
that INF France here from the effect to
the cause but of course you know nobody
who had witnessed this here would have
been able to predict the existence of
the plague for centuries later right it
would have been if you had predicted
that you would have been insan same um
so that's a case where you know if you
want to put it in terms of probabilities
the probability of the effect given the
C is very high but the probability of
the the effect given the C sorry the the
probability of the effect given the C is
very low but the probability of the Cs
given the effect is very high right so
again I want to think about what
explains this at a very general abstract
level what explains this asymmetry here
um and you looking first at the exam at
sort of the cause to effect direction
right uh it's obvious why nobody would
have predicted the existence of the
plague for centuries later if they had
witnessed the departure of the ship bra
because uh you know the departure of the
ship obviously was not causally
sufficient for the existence of the
plague a staggeringly large number of
other factors had to be in place in 1620
to later lead to that event right so
that includes you know all the factors
that would later make the Mayflower or
its departure a significant event in
world history so you know uh facts about
the weather that would ensure that the
ship doesn't sink and gets forgotten you
know facts about uh the one pag people
who would provide assistance to the
ship's passengers in Massachusetts and
so on and also facts about you know uh
facts that would later lead to the
emergence of plague making as an
important practice uh of memorialization
in in the 19th century and so on and so
on and of course you know there's
there's a clear sense in which uh
you know those factors all lining up in
the right way that was enormously
unlikely right and that's why you know
just witnessing again that event here uh
would not have let you predict predict
this and I think this is a more you know
there's there's a general story here as
to to why it's so hard to predict uh
events in the future especially the
distant future from from their
causes uh If You observe and even see
here that's like going to produce an
event e uh whether is going to happen
that's also going to depend on many
other causal factors right and if the
event is is you know it's in the distant
future um often you're going to need an
enormous amount of such factors and the
probability that they're going to line
up in the right way it's going to be
very low and that's why you know
observing the C alone that's not going
to uh tell you that the effect Happ
happened right the probability of that
is going to be to be very
low um and so one lesson here is that um
you I mentioned this epistemic
predicament that we face that we can
only make local
observations uh but we live in a world
governed by global laws right well one
consequ one one idea is that um at least
when it comes to predict the when it
comes to predicting the future um that
predicament is very severe right right
uh the fact that the laws are Global
means that a local cause is always is
never going to be sufficient for its
effect you're always going to need more
factors to entail it uh and that means
you know to make a reliable predictions
you would have to be able to observe all
of this but that's going to be spread
over an enormous spatial region and and
of course you know we can't make
observations like that right we're
limited to observing the things around
us so hope y so far I mean again this is
highly highly abstract story but I hope
it makes sense and perhaps it strike you
as perfectly trivial even hopefully uh
where things get interesting is if you
think about what happens in the reverse
Direction when you go from
uh uh from effect to C so now when
you're you know you're reading the pl
and learning about this event here
because I said you know that's here we
want to say intuitively the the
probability of the Cs given the effect
here it's very high right
but it's sort of a mystery how that can
be the case because the global character
of the physical lws that you know makes
it impossible to predict the future it's
also present towards the past uh the
global character of flows it's um it's a
Time symmetric feature of the L
um what and what that means is that uh
just like a local cause is never
sufficient for a later effect given the
lose likewise local event is never
sufficient for its past
cause um given the L the ls are always
going to tell you you know uh whether
the C really happened depends not only
on that that local events but on what
happens in an enormous spatial uh region
um again to to figure out what happens
here on the basis of there you need you
know the lws the laws need information
about everything that happens that
happens here right uh to make this a bit
more concrete uh you know one one way to
see this or to see that uh you know the
case of our little plague here does it's
not sufficient given the loss for this
to happen or to have happened is to
think about all the other effects of the
departure of the Mayflower that are sort
of scatered in the micro state of the
world right now so this includes things
like uh you know statements in
encyclopedias uh monuments to the
Mayflower uh memories in the brains of
historians and school children and so on
right and imagine for a second that all
those other records you know say nothing
about the Mayflower or say that it
departed at some other date or something
right uh well presumably then the L
would say the plague is most likely the
result of a mistake or a prank or
something like that right now the L
would say okay this this p c never
really happened uh so that's one way to
see that you know whether this thing
really happens as far as the L are
concerned it depends on what happens
globally over here but again you know
just seeing this here is enough to make
the inference so there that's sort of a
mystery again uh and uh the f is this is
again a general General feature there's
nothing specific about my example uh
whenever you see a local effect he here
and your trying to predict a past Co C
of it uh well whether the C really
happened as far as the physical laws are
concerned that's also going to depend on
uh all the other effects of c and if all
those effect all those other effects are
are absent or if they say something
different then the laws are going to
tell you C most likely didn't didn't
happen uh so the upshut here is that we
have this this sort of deep symmetry at
the physical levels between cause to
effect inference and effect to cause
inference right and the question is what
breaks the Symmetry what makes it so
that uh here the priority of the the
effect given the call is very low but
here the priority of the calls given
given the effect it's it can be can be
very very
high um but I think if you think about
it in terms of causal modeling and the a
symmetry between causes and effects
that's encapsulated in the causal Mark
of condition then uh the answer becomes
becomes clear
um you the Cal Mark of condition it's
going to tell you looking looking first
at the the sort of CA to effect case
right uh those variables here C and the
other causes of they're they're
exogenous variables right um so the caal
mark of condition tells you uh there's
not going to be any correlation between
C and the other causes of the effect
you're trying to to
predict um and that's why the
probability of e given that effect that
that call alone has to be very
low one way to say this is suppose that
c was correlated with all those other
conditions X1 X2 and so on then the
simple occurrence of C would make those
conditions very likely and therefore the
occurrence of e also very likely as well
right so here just observing C would
provide a lot of information about
what's going to happen happen in the
future that's precisely the sort of uh
correlation between exogenous variables
that's forbidden by the coal Mark of
condition in the case of the Mayflower
the coal Mark of condition says you're
not going to find a correlation between
say the departure of a ship from a
harbor and all the other conditions
required to make that departure
memorable for centuries later right um
and that's why just observing the
departure of the ship doesn't doesn't
make the effect likely at
all and the reason that uh this doesn't
apply in Reverse is
that here now we're dealing with effects
of a common cause right the effect
you're observing and all the other
effects of see there their effect of a
common cause and here the caal mark of
condition says you those things are can
and and generally will be correlated
with one
another and I means the probability of
of C given e alone again can be very
high all that this requires is that
there be a strong correlation between e
and the other effects of of C that's all
that's required for this thing over here
to make that thing very
likely uh so if you think of it in terms
of my
example again plagues generally make the
events they report very likely right
plagues are reliable in general uh if
you go around reading plagues you're
going to get it right most of the time
how can that be given that the events
they report as far as the laws are
concerned also depend on many other
things in the micro state of the world
well the answer is that the content of
those plages is strongly correlated with
other records of those past events of
you know memories in the brains of
historians monuments what encyclopedias
say and so on right so that's why you
don't need to consult the
encyclopedias or as the historian and so
on right just reading the plague is
enough okay so the the object here is
then um if that's right it's really the
caal mark of condition that explains why
we can infer so much about the past but
little about about the future and again
to repeat this one more time the the
background here is that we face this
problem that the physical laws are
Global but we can only make local
observations so there's this mystery as
to how we can ever infer anything from
those local
observations and the far is the
distinction between causes and effects
explains why that predicament is really
severe when we try to infer the future
but it's not so severe when we try to
infer the the
past and the IDE is you if you make a
look local observation if you see a
local event over here it's not going to
be correlated with all the other
causes of the effects it's going to
produce in the future so the observation
by itself doesn't tell you much about
the
future um but the local event You
observe it's going to be correlated with
all the other effects of its past
causes uh and that's why your local
observation alone can give you a lot of
information about about the past
um I'm not sure how much time I have
left pre do you know when I
started four minutes four minutes if you
want yeah okay I'll I'll I'll just uh I
I'll you know uh one thing I I like
about the story I've just told is uh it
explains why we can sometimes predict
the future um the special context in
which we can predict the future these
are context where you know one of the
sort of principles have appealed to
explaining why predicting the future is
hard uh one of those principles is not
going to be uh it's not going to hold so
when you're dealing with isolated
systems for example um here you're
you're dealing with a system where it's
future it's future State Sor is
determined by only a small number of
variables right and uh the probability
that sort of outside circumstances are
going to disrupt the system is just very
very low right so just making a few
local observations about this system is
going to be able to predict what's going
to happen in the future but of course
you know our lives and you know
economies and political systems the
things we're interested in predicting
they're not isolated systems right what
happens in their future it always lies
on the intersection of multiple
independent causal lines and that's why
we can't we can't really predict about
them uh immediate future uh the story
like in my cooking pen example right
where I can predict the fire alarm is
going to beep in a few seconds the idea
here is you know if the if the effect is
really in the near future there's not
much room for other conditions to make a
difference uh so here local observation
is going to be enough to predict what's
going to happen fairly soon and then
broad brush predictions you know I know
that the Russian invasion is going to
have some consequences in the future I
don't know what they are well the
thought here is you know
um if you make a ve if you predict a
very generic and specific effect
the sort of outside conditions that are
required for that effect to happen
they're also going to be very generic
and you can sort of safely assume
they're in place so here the you know
you can you can uh predict what's going
what might happen in the sort of distant
future as long as you remain very vague
and very very
unspecific
um couple of questions um you know what
about m memories I haven't really talked
about memories as another way to know
about the past uh that we can't apply to
the Future um things to say about this
but um won say them today there a you
skipping the second Point here there's
also a question about you know if you
think about it in terms of physics here
uh this asymmetry that you find in Cal
Mark of condition where does it come
from all the far is it's going to come
at the end of the day from certain facts
about the initial state of the universe
maybe some sort of initial Randomness
condition something like that um so
that's how at the end of the day you're
going to explain why you know how time
symmetric physics gives rise to this
sort of time and symmetry of of
knowledge and of and of
inference um maybe I I'll stop here uh
I'll just leave uh you know summary of
the some of the some of the main points
and uh you know there's a paper you know
if you're if you're interested in uh
looking at it here there's a there's a
link over here so so thank you
[Applause]
thanks so much um Thomas um
questions so I'm I'm a little puzzled
whenever I hear this kind of thing
because the the examples seem to be kind
of cherry-picked and I can cherry-pick
them the other direction um of course
you've got systems to make any
predictions they have to be pretty
isolated because if stuff's going to
come from the outside okay so let have
an isolated system um it could have a
chaotic Dynamics then I'm going to have
trouble predicting it it could have a
dissipative Dynamics and I'm have really
good chance I'll predict well and I'll
retrodict badly right I have a a room
and I say all right it's isolated it's
been isolated for 5 minutes it's going
to be isolated for 5 minutes there's a
little ball sitting on the on the carpet
and I say in 5 minutes that Ball's going
to be sitting there right on that carpet
what was it doing 3 minutes ago who
knows could have been been rolling in
right cuz the friction it's going to
dissipate so I can predict well I can
retrodict badly um I see the rain
outside and I say well I can now make a
pretty good prediction that it'll that
that that it will say
rain in the papers tomorrow that means
from the papers tomorrow I can make a
good retrodiction that it did rain today
from the seeing the rain today I can't
retrodict what the papers said yesterday
I mean it it seems to me there's no real
pattern here at all um so I'm not really
sure what's what even the the datm is
that we're supposed to be explaining
because you can pick examples that go
this way and I can pick other examples
that go the other way and it has to do
with chaotics it has to do with
dissipation there all kinds of how
stable things are um I see a plaque what
should I infer about what happened well
if I'm in 1984 I have to know a whole
lot about you know is is the ministry of
Truth controlling what's on plaques
maybe I can infer from the plaque that
nothing like that happen I mean maybe I
can't infer anything so it seems to me
the whole situation is just you know
kind of much more messy than this
suggests yeah I mean I I
uh I agree with a lot of what you said
and I think you know if you want to I
mean I still think there is some sort of
difference uh it's very subtle how to uh
sort of exactly express it um you know
the best I can do is have this this
claim about you know there's a sense in
which the context that where prediction
is
possible there's a sense in which
they're special or at least you know we
can s of listem it's about isolated
systems or the immediate future and so
on but is when it comes to to you know
to inferences towards the past there are
certain limitations that don't hold
right it doesn't have to be about the
immediate past it doesn't have to be an
isolated system and so um and the
thought is you know this the story here
is supposed to explain why uh why that's
the
case um so you can think of the story as
as saying you know there is one obstacle
to predicting the future it has to do
with the globality of the laws of
physics um why isn't that obstacle an
obstacle to inferring the past well the
answer is you know something about
causation but of course that doesn't
mean we can infer uh you know we can
infer everything about the past we can't
you know retrodict the trajectory of the
ball uh you know there's going to be
plenty of situations where there's just
limits to what we can uh
retrodict um what's going to be the
explanation for that well I don't think
that's going to be sort of a general
physical explanation it's at this at
this point you know it's going to be
Case by case in the case of plagues you
know has to do with you know the sort of
social practices we have and why there's
no Ministry of Truth so on right in the
case of footprints it's going to be
something about you know themodynamics
and human anatomy and so on uh so
there's going to be lots of little local
stories but if there is something Global
to say I think it that's something like
like what I
said if I may ask take the
prerogative so um I'm slightly confused
so I want a clarification sure so is one
of the issues that predicting the future
state is sort of handicapped by the lack
of information it's not about the lost
but the lack of information of the full
list of relevant causes right so it's
incomplete information about causes that
may become relevant in the future which
we cannot enumerate at the present time
with local observations absolutely yeah
but the part is you know if you look at
the physics you can get in a mood where
that also applies towards the past and
you know the information I have it's
also in a sense very incomplete right to
to retrodict the Past because you know
the laws of physics tell me it also
depends on what happens in this enormous
fre chain I mean this is of course we're
speaking about everything in terms of
deterministic yeah I mean yeah yeah yeah
yeah relating into
probabilistic right of course
yeah thank you very inspiring and my
question relates to the previous
questions the first one is the way that
you've been using laws um and Global
laws for me seems to and maybe you can
confirm this that you have a very
reductionist logic so that you the
Mayflower as a phenomenon is a set of
laws or is due to a set of laws of
physics which for me yeah May if that's
correct I'm curious to know if that's an
explicit assumption for you and the
other one which I'm interested in is is
about the the plaque and why is the
plaque something that we should infer
the existence of the Mayflower from
because if I understand your story
correctly that what is happening in this
asymmetry is that the effects are
correlated and because of this
correlation we can do we have this
asymmetry and the causes they're not
correlated so that's why it's harder to
go to the Future than um go to the past
so then why does a single
plaque have the authority or or the
capability of showing you that this
Mayflower should exist if if you're
saying that why is it not a set of
effects that make that we can go back to
the past easier than that we can go to
the Future so why is it is it not
something in the plaque that makes that
there's already a set of correlations
happening why the thing that you you
said about some social phenomena that
this plaque is made in certain
conditions or the fact that we we if we
want to actually understand the
Mayflower and that we're not in some um
some Disneyland plaque that says
something about the existence of Captain
Hook um um and a ship and that we need
these type of correlations to actually
do that yeah uh I forgot the first
question was about your logic and your
reductionism all of this is yeah I mean
the all sorts of of reductionistic
assumptions uh in place here sort of I
guess common ground in that debate so uh
you know the Mayflower that's a physical
system um it's at the end of the day go
governed
you know entirely and ultimately by the
physical laws and so there's a mystery
as to you know you know explaining how
in terms of the law of physics we can
make you know we can make certain
inferences about the system but not not
all of this yeah yeah so yeah very large
scale assumptions in place here uh the
second one I mean not sure what to say
here um you know one thing you know this
is a specific example and of course
there's going to be very specific things
to say about what PL why plagues are
reliable and so on but the idea is you
know well the point here is to try to to
tell a much more abstract and general
story and you know to put it in in those
abstract terms there is you
know we find very strong correlations
between things in the present and things
in the past we find few correlations
in the future I mean qualify that in all
sorts of ways and so on uh and yeah is
you know the physics of our World it
seems to prevent those correlations
anyway whatever Direction
uh and far is you know it's the caal
structure of the world that explains the
the the solution then after after that
you know if you want to explain you know
why are plagues specifically very
strongly correlated with the events Day
Report well again it's going to be a
local story about you know human
practices and uh you know why you know
the people who commission the plages
have an interest in you know having
reliable ones and so on uh uh but the
point is you know to to to have the sort
of much more abstract much more General
story on the the
table uh yeah thanks so much for your
talk uh so I'm totally on board with
understanding the causal asymmetry in
terms of this probabilistic
asymmetry and I was curious whether you
see as part of your project as trying to
say something about why those
asymmetries get manifested given the way
the universe is so even given everything
you've said if you did not have
independent causes um then you know it
would all you it would trivially be true
but unhelpful caal marker would apply
you couldn't use it for anything uh so
and it seems to me there are sort of
ongoing debates about this so I mean so
so I take the story someone like Dan
hman says I mean he appeals basically to
the same asymmetry and he would say you
know that there's uh no causation in
closed deterministic system so it's only
when we course grain and consider sort
of you know open subsystems and it
seemed to me the orientation of your
talk went in that direction Mattias
frish disagrees so I mean kind of I'm
curious whether this is part of your
project to then say something about that
uh yeah good thanks uh I'm more on the
yeah I'm I'm more on the side of you
know the the Cal symmetry it sort of
emerges when you're CA graining the
system um and and you get
probabilities and so on
um you know this is
as you mentioned this is something on
which people have have had a lot to say
and I don't have much more to add to
this this is sort of the background
you're right uh but I think you know if
you think about the caal asymmetry in
totally different terms as this sort of
fundamental arrows there is in the world
right uh you know perhaps people who
have sort of more robust metaphysics are
inclined to think of it that way you
know we can also tell that story I think
yeah last question okay we have two
andent really
reflecting I was pressing it I
wasn't only press it once right excuse
me I hav gathered that
obviously so um it feels as if the
history is very protected in the case of
the Mayflower it really takes an effort
of will over centuries for the plaque to
exist and if something is forgotten then
refining it can be a huge effort and if
there's an effort of will is is imposed
to deliberately forget so a criminal
wants an act not to be remembered then
the the will to forget it becomes a very
serious part of whether it is remembered
whether it whether there is a
commemoration so how would you see
willpower just the will the human will
figuring into this
that's interesting yeah yeah um yeah
you're you're absolutely right here that
you know uh in this example I mean
there's a lot to say about sort of you
know human practices of uh memorializing
certain events and not others and you
know uh yeah I don't have anything sort
of insightful to say to say about this
um the idea is you know uh at a c
certain level
uh you know the Mayflower thing
you you could you could use examples
that have nothing to do with human
action and human uh practices to tell
the point I mean you know this fil over
there uh you know it's a sign of uh the
existence of the species you know
millions or billions of years ago uh but
physics tells me you know whether that
species really existed it depends on not
only the the existence of that fil but
actually the entire cross-section of the
of the forward light cone right and of
course there's not there's perhaps not
going to be any other microscopic signs
of the existence of that species maybe
the fil is the only microscopic record
we have but at the microscopic levels uh
you know uh there's still going to be uh
you know
correlations uh again the for is you
know how is that possible you know how
is it possible for the fossil to still
provide information if that's the case
uh
yeah hey thank you for the great talk uh
so what I want to ask is that certainly
at the neonian level uh there is time
reversal symmetry in the laws uh but at
the quantum field Theory level would
there be uh because CPT is preserved and
We Know by an matter antimatter symmet
CP is violated so time reversal wouldn't
hold at the quantum uh field Theory
level um so maybe that gives a new
perspective of how how like this
symmetry might
arise this is a great question and I've
I have absolutely nothing to say on this
is um actually the cosm
dis this is you know this is outside of
my my my area of
uh not completing competence I guess
um and I wish I wish somebody who was
knowledgeable about those issues you
know would would uh would answer I guess
you know one thing to say is uh you
know the sort of inferences we we make
you know they're based on microscopic
phenomena and you know at the
microscopic level I mean I assume the
Dynamics is you know it's kind of Quasi
deterministic right uh
so I'm per skeptical that you know going
to the fundamental levels is going to
sort of tell you or you know provide the
answer here or uh because again you know
whatever asymmetry you're going to find
it doesn't really seem to percolate up
guess but again you know I don't know
much about
those I mean I can answer that question
um you might worry it in quantum theory
if you've got a fundamental collapse
Theory a fundamentally indeterministic
Theory then you might be able to predict
and not retrodict okay but CPT has
nothing to do with it because even if
you as long as you obey CPT there's
going to be information preservation at
the global scale in both directions
that's not going to break that that'll
be perfectly symmetric right from
perfect information at any time you can
get perfect information at any other
time say that information is not
preserved yeah but the the time reversal
you said the time reversal is broken the
relevant time reversal isn't relevant
time reversal is the is the preservation
of information in both
directions uh thanks once again th thank
you